what we have here is a graph of y is
equal to f of x and these numbers are
the areas of these shaded regions these
regions between our curve and the x-axis
and we're going to do in this video is
do some examples of evaluating definite
integrals using this information and
some knowledge of definite integral
properties so let's start with an
example let's say we want to evaluate
the definite integral going from
negative 4 to negative 2
of f of x
d of x plus the definite integral going
from negative 2 to 0 of f of x
dx pause this video and see if you can
evaluate this entire expression
so this first part of our expression the
definite integral from negative 4 to
negative 2 of f of x dx we're going from
x equals negative 4 to x equals negative
2.
and so
this would evaluate as
this area between our curve and our
x-axis but it would be the negative of
that area because our curve is below the
x-axis and we could try to estimate it
based on the information they've given
us but they haven't given us exactly
that value
but we also need to figure out this
right over here and here we're going
from x equals negative 2 to 0
of f of x d of x so that's going to be
this area
so if you're looking at the sum of these
two definite integrals and notice the
upper bound here is the lower bound here
you're really thinking about this is
really going to be the same thing as
this is equal to
the definite integral going from x
equals negative 4 all the way to x
equals 0 of f of x
dx and this is indeed one of our
integration properties if our upper
bound here is the same as our lower
bound here and we are integrating the
same thing well then you can merge these
two definite integrals in this way and
this is just going to be this entire
area but because we are below the x-axis
and above our curve here it would be the
negative of that area so this is going
to be equal to negative seven
let's do another example
let's say someone were to ask you walk
walk up to you on the street and say
quick what here's a graph
what is the
the the value of the expression that i'm
about to write down the definite
integral going from 0 to 4 of f of x dx
plus the definite integral going from
4 to 6 of f of x
dx pause this video and see if you can
figure that out well once again
this first part right over here going
from 0 to
4.
so what would be is would be this area
it would be this 5 right over here
but then we would need to subtract this
area because this area is below our
x-axis and above our curve we don't know
exactly what this is but luckily we also
need we need to take the sum of
everything i just
everything i just showed but plus plus
this right over here
and this we're going from 4 to 6 so it's
going to be this area
well once again when you look at it this
way you can see that this expression is
going to be equivalent to taking the
definite integral all the way from 0 to
0 to 6 of f of x
dx and once again even if you didn't see
the graph you would know that because in
both cases you're getting the definite
integral of f of x dx and our upper
bound here is our lower bound here so
once again we're able to merge the
integrals and what is this going to be
equal to
well we have this area here which is 5
and then we have this area which is 6
that was given to us but since it's
below the x-axis and above our curve
when we evaluate it as a definite
integral it would evaluate as a negative
6. so this is going to be 5 plus
negative 6 which is equal to negative
one and we're done